and uh so Umesh asked me to do this to
moderate this panel I think because I'm
I'm a vision guy so I have healthy
suspicion of language and so I'll be a
little bit adversarial uh but the I hope
that we will get and I'm I'm actually
pretty sure that we will get the
speakers to disagree with each other
which is usually what makes for a good
panel
um so let me start with with the first
question
um which is so llms right now are like
these eager bookish teenager they are
built they are just going through
binging on four Millennia worth of
written uh cultural history okay
and
questions first
when do you think they will finish
going through all of the data that is
historical text Data available when will
that happen a second question what will
happen after
well will will our performance plateau
uh what would be when the that that fire
hydrant worth of data turns into
proverbial Trickle and also probably
poisoned by some of the generative text
as well what will happen next
whoever wants to start
a question are you referring to just uh
language data or all the languages no no
language yeah
um yeah
yeah
okay
um yeah so I mean people I think
disagree quite a bit as to sort of how
much useful language data there is out
there I mean on the one hand it seems
like you can kind of think that
um
models are already trading on most of
the good data that's out there in
another sense there's obviously sort of
hugely more data available sort of
buried in every kind of cooperation data
store but you know
presumably getting less and less
incremental value from it so I mean I
think that the first you know
notwithstanding the phenomenal amounts
of money that open AI anthropic predicts
spending on Next Generation models I
actually kind of think the first thing
that's going to run out is useful data
and so that that will put the brakes on
progress but I think this is an enormous
opportunity for machine learning because
I think the really important thing to
remember is that even though these huge
models like gpt4 whoa they're fantastic
the reality is that at this point
they're learning I'm about a hundred
thousand times as much data uh as little
humans get before their productive
language users and so that suggests that
they're not actually very good machine
Learners and that they're still just
huge opportunity to come up with better
machine Learners in future years
laughs
[Laughter]
you might actually know how long you
have left
you know
it's a great question
for for obvious reasons I I can't go too
much into too much details in what I'll
say but
I think it will be I think we will
discover that it is possible too
continue to keep making progress despite
those
real obstacles
[Laughter]
and this photo
is this okay good at least for the data
side I think there is a lot of copyright
data you have the government allows us
to use copyright data there
at least I think there is a thousand
times more I don't know just random
guessing at I don't know
uh I just wanted to point out that you
know there's some tension between the
two things you said uh which is that
current learning is very inefficient by
some very large Factor and that
therefore more data would not help to me
that it seems the opposite that when you
begin to learn more efficiently maybe
you'll squeeze more out of the same data
that seems completely plausible
is that what you meant okay sorry okay
so therefore
you don't run out of data in that sense
yes
what about all of the all of the data
that uh that get generated that is fake
data basically
yeah so just completely speculating what
you know open AI or other companies may
or may not do in the future uh I kind of
feel like they might find a lot more
data uh that they they haven't or you
know some companies haven't uh
discovered yet but plus I I suspect that
AI synthesized the data might be a lot
more enabling
um not only for the small models that
you know I tend to train which also was
based on synthesized data after all but
also for training the larger models
going forward but of course I can only
speculate
thoughts
[Laughter]
you know it's gonna be there is a risk
of a slightly boring panel what what
I'll say is I think I think that many of
the ideas that were presented just now
were all quite sensible and plausible
[Laughter]
okay A little follow-up so again you
know a lot of the talks today were about
algorithms I want to push more on the
data side a lot of the speakers said
well I don't know if there's this and
this on the internet right so
it seems like it would be very useful to
actually understand not just algorithm
but understand the data understand what
is there in the in the in the internet
uh for example are there tables of three
by three multiplication somewhere in
there or maybe even four by four tables
right
um what um yeah what what is the you
know how can we basically disentangle
this
you know uh High dimensional
interpolation and capabilities which are
which are quite impressive from the true
generalization actually you know
creating something that that wasn't
there before how how do we understand
the data that's out there to to actually
disentangle those two things
yeah so uh I'll mention briefly in my
talk tomorrow that you know that you can
just do a random sampling approach like
uh basically you start with a only the
generative setting you know like you
start with the list of
and skills you can or whatever you can
call it uh reasoning and linguistic
skills and uh
you can randomly sample K of them so
like five of them so now they are and
choose five combinations and then you
can pick some very esoteric topic you
can put constraints on it like the topic
is you know baseball in the Caribbean or
something so it's a fairly small part of
the internet
and then you know you can ask the model
to generate text on it and uh and if it
can then it shows that you know it's at
least imagining a situation
using your constraints which doesn't
exist in the data with high probability
and that uh well gpd4 does pretty well
in my testing and uh the other models
struggle a bit but they also do it to
some extent
thank you
um so uh if you're not in the morning
session I talked about how gpt2 off the
shelf is completely hopeless but uh if
you're really willing to look up uh look
out for a good hidden sample so that
gpt2 actually is capable of generating
it's just that it's not willing unless
you somehow put more decoding algorithms
on top or other strategies on top and it
doesn't know that it should assign high
probability to it but technical is
speaking it's capable of generating them
and so if you discover those then uh
it's if they you have a good reward
model or filter model that can assign
good scores to them then that serves as
AI synthesize the data that AI can fit
on so that's a bit of clarification on
why I said earlier that AI synthesized
data could be really enabling because
inherently the generator is capable of
General ordering them it just doesn't
know that it should assign higher scores
for them uh yeah then so that requires a
bit of a human intervention but um
having said that although maybe the Jeep
even gpt2 may have like this um
infinitely many strings that is capable
of generating uh in my experience
especially thinking about common sense
uh reasoning uh coming up with really
Corner cases that even gpt4 cannot
handle it's not that easy to
systematically somehow generate all
these weird Corner problems that you
know nobody actually think about but
maybe you know for the purpose of making
a talk I might cook up something so uh
in that sense it seems that there's a
fundamental limit as to how exhaustively
can you pick a data set and then really
exhaustively enumerate them all
so
so I have a comment on this as well I
think it's a very deep question like
how much do the models memorize and how
much of the generalized
can everything they do be reduced to
memorization
I think it's a very valid question
and I would like to offer a way of
thinking about it
one thing I'll say is that our standards
for what constitutes memorization have
been increasing
over the years
there was a time where language models
used to be engram models these models
are so have not been used for so long
that it's possible that many of you here
have never heard this word before anger
models those are models which basically
they say
um
[Laughter]
they I I'm sorry I I didn't hear what
you said so I don't know what the joke
was
I mean
it's uh
it's stuff it's tough it's tough out
there but um
the
those models would predict text by
finding an exact
phrase
in the train set so it says okay yes you
say I'm going for a
or what comes next it's going to say
well let's look at all the occurrences
of I'm going for it in the text and
see what you find
now
more than 10 years ago Google would
already train engram models on trillions
of words
and they would still find that you have
like the Ingram model
would suffer from the curse of
dimensionality the curse of
dimensionality is something which was
also commonly mentioned in for example
um High dimensional statistics contexts
before deep learning I would argue solve
it we no longer mention the curse of
dimensionality anymore we are now we are
our context lengths now are in the
thousands and we are totally fine and we
can usefully benefit from them so
something really very different is
happening I want to mention one other
thing about memorization memorization
versus not memorization and this is the
difference in performance in a different
generations of models
you know it's true that the information
about like how much data those models
are trained on isn't exactly public but
you can kind of make an educated guess
of like an upper bound of the increase
of the amount of data and you can say
okay if you go to the previous model and
it clearly couldn't do some things and
you say yeah the next model does them
and it does them because of memorization
it must be that like Okay so
would an engram model succeed if it was
trained on the same data the answer is
obviously no also like when we say
memorization now say oh yeah like if it
paraphrases the idea in a totally
different way but it's the same idea it
comes as memorization
I think it's a
I think it's a stretch but it is true
that these models are definitely
non-human in the way they learn because
they need so much more data they need so
much more data they are not human
they're generally generalization is not
quite human yet while also being
surprisingly human-like in their
representations and errors in many but
not always
are actually quite related to engram
models basically if you think of a
diagram models with a dynamic n that is
sort of input specific it's not really
that that far of a jump absolutely and
emphatically no absolutely not
like a Transformer is a computer
it is a computer which does parallel
computation
it is a computer that is programmed
automatically with gradient descent
it can like run algorithms on the inside
it is a completely different
line one could say that engrams could
run very simple programs too by by
lookup kind of Chinese Aroma argument no
I don't think so because the Chinese
like the thing is okay
so the mechanism of the engram algorithm
there is no there is no there's no
algorithm there pretty much it's like
you look this thing up and if it's there
you're good the neural network does the
actual computation so indeed the Chinese
room argument requires an exponentially
large but keep in mind like I feel like
in in the early CS education they really
stress the difference between
exponential and polynomial and I feel
like we kind of forgot it you know what
I mean like an Ingram model for it to be
good you need like a legitimately an
exponential amount of data like two to
the 700 tokens maybe something like this
go to the 500 analog
something of this order
it's like it's a different universe
um maybe um I would like to add a little
bit on the you know whether how much of
it is memorized versus actually
generalized so when I look at
um even gbt2 output I felt that uh it's
generating things that that's not quote
unquote completely memorized about
generalized so there were some novelty
in it for sure
um but I wonder whether there are two
different wildly different types of
novelty or creativity such that there's
more of interpolation type novelty where
you know you've never seen maybe avocado
chair before but you've seen avocado and
chair and then able to combine both of
them in a brand new you know uh way and
similarly you know you ask where the
questions to charge a PT that presumably
no one else asked about but it's able to
make some interpolation between the
lawyer style language that Chachi Piti
tends to speak with the particular
content that you provided with so that
it's doing some brand new output that
may have not existed in the training
data but having said that hypothetically
um I wonder if there's a really
different level of novelty like you know
for example Hemingway writing Hemingway
style novels for the first time in the
humanity before anyone else does so if
hypothetically open AI removes all of
that from pre-training data and then
somehow prompt engineer GPT 4 or 5 or 6
that please write in a brand new style
of writing uh and you know try to
encourage you to win a I don't know some
like a price whether it's going to be
able to really come up with something
genuinely genuinely novel and by the way
of course these are difficult for humans
as well it's not just for GP whatever
that's difficult but similarly like a
major breakthrough with
um theories uh maybe it's a more
question for you but do you envision
that or for anyone else in this room
um this sort of a novelty can be
achieved through the sort of
unsupervised learning that we're
currently doing
foreign
which is kind of falling on that and
it's uh goes going to be a little bit
more philosophical and but uh Chris's uh
talk gave me permission to be
philosophical so
um
Chris mentioned that it's uh bacteria to
Bach right and uh and and the thing is
that if if you think about it the
language is evolutionary you know the
last five minutes of of of development
right so most of that thing was done
before like so in a sense what we are
doing right now is we're kind of
chugging away the bacteria and basically
starting starting directly into with
Bach right and and and so
you know is is this okay are we okay
with basically forgetting about
darwinian uh uh intelligence and going
directly to George uh you're in the
intelligence uh kind of skipping all of
the fun stuff because in a sense you
know I would think that you know Bach
became buff because you know his
ancestors were you know hunting and
Gathering and had pain and suffering and
were you know developed language
eventually and tried to communicate
through language and from music that
pain and suffering isn't that kind of
needed to to get to this true
generalization that that we're talking
about
yes
I mean it's sort of hard to know with
the pain and suffering and if those have
or will ever have any analog
um with digital devices but I mean I do
subscribe to you know this
um following Duality you know on the one
hand it's been
just amazing how much can be achieved
from nothing but a language model I
think almost no one
thought possible how much you could do
with simply building a model on a huge
amount of language it's just been Way
Beyond everyone's expectations but on
the other hand I think it's clearly not
enough and you could even believe that
if your future AI like a kid developed
first some better models of causality
that come from the kind of stimulus
response experiments that little kids do
with their powers of blocks and things
like that that would actually give them
a much better basis for doing the kind
of causal modeling of the world that I
think that will be necessary to get
beyond the almost entirely associative
learning that's done in Transformers
foreign
having to read the entire internet does
sound like software
[Laughter]
personally I don't think those
experiences lovely little there is
people who is Biomat cannot see and
cannot hear and can still be intelligent
and and our ancestors suffers
suffered yeah but they they don't really
carry those memory from them at least I
don't know any suffering that make me
know how to do math
and also I feel to be creative I think
one baby of creative is someone need to
able to know what is a good idea and
what is a bad idea and I think that the
the current GPT one one problem is just
it cannot tell preaching good and bad
sometimes especially if it will involve
reasoning and if it can start verifying
it I feel GPT is like pure says MP if it
know how to MP then we can start before
saying and then maybe you can solve your
opposes one day if it can tell between a
good proof versus bad proof
yeah just to point out obvious I mean
once if you have these uh agents
embodied in some way and then they're
training on their experiences then
basically you're getting there
so uh but that's exactly where what we
are not doing
at this point primarily probably for AI
safe series rather than any other reason
I would guess
I think we just don't have as much of a
public data I mean the thing about
language is that internet
happened and then we all contributed
contributed to the the repository of
language uh in large quantity but we you
know let I mean we sometimes do share
photos and videos about uh not anywhere
close to the amount of a text out there
and then for uh more like you know
robots uh the manipulation and all that
it really requires a little bit more
personalized
um uh different kinds of visual signals
compared to the photographs that you
take in a very selective way in your
life so the nature of the data there's
uh some gap between or significant to
get between what's actually freely
available on online versus uh what we
might really need if we were to train
this vision and Robotics models in the
way that llms are trained what I mean by
that is right now it's a little bit like
a brute force on a lot of human data and
then we try to sort of like bypass
bacteria and go straight toward the bug
but uh that that recipe seems to require
a lot of data available and uh there's a
data bottleneck where the multimodal
models and
and I also find one form of those images
there are less information than compared
to test
in some sense the internet the
information is already not very tense
most of them are junk but if you look at
the image stated then or window data
then you it's way harder to extract
anything
that's the challenge
yeah I think the interacting agents
probably might be very powerful
um because if we just look at human
history in the last 150 years
perfect sec to the next question which
is
what I thought would be super exciting
and kind of terrifying would be indeed
some sort of llms in a loop where they
would be updating themselves or or
learning to run ride better uh Python
scripts or some way you know I mean the
best thing of course if it if it's done
in the real world but even in the
virtual world some sort of like how to
gbt kind of scenarios and it it sounds
like there was some early excitement
about that but then at least I haven't
heard much is there some particular is
there a bottleneck that they all hit or
are things coming and it's going to be
it's going to be all explode very soon
what's what what are people thinking
well let's see
for several questions asked right the
question what's the deal with the auto
GPT that's built on top of the current
models
I mean yeah it does appear that current
models as used as used as present
they don't support interest the current
Implement I'll make the statement the
current implementation of other GPT
that's based on prompting and so on yeah
it does not support particularly amazing
things
but indeed this kind of Loops which
you're alluded are possible in principle
and once once unlocked I think we will
see all kinds of strange and different
things compared to what we are used to
and we should be
it's like you know if you have
studied learning right like all the
things that were happening I figured out
that if you use more data more compute
that's like your magical formula right
and that leads to this kind of very
reliable almost yearly Cadence of
advances
at some point perhaps there'll be a
different formula but you already have
those big computers so the formula it's
like you have a lot of
the computer is ready to go and you
might see some very when that happens we
might see someone
less continuous changes and indeed your
point I'm a primal care will be needed
so do you have any sense of what is what
is the current what is preventing it
right now like why is self-play or
something like this or whenever left
doesn't work it
I mean I don't know maybe
how to answer
maybe there's like something small that
people haven't
I figured out to have it considered
trying you know how those things are in
machine learning right you need to get
like you need to get four things and all
the four things need to be there and if
like you go back to the whole deep
learning forget the names it's not gonna
work even if you have the data set
you've got the computer you've got the
learning rate you don't have the in it
then it is wrong the whole thing is not
gonna work it might be something like
this
so are any of the speakers think that
there's a fundamental reason this
wouldn't work you know there are some
algorithms that you run once it's fine
but when you when you put them in a loop
they they fail it this this is not the
case here or is there or do it
everything this is just a matter of time
maybe I'll have another comment so
to the best of my knowledge
in
theoretical computer science
it's hard to prove that something that a
particular model family can do something
right this I believe this is true people
here can confirm
the same situation is kind of here in a
similar situation with those AI systems
right like you say okay we have some
new big great model
they say well we can't do this well are
you sure what if you change the prompt a
little bit
so and in fact people are discovering
these kind of things all the time
they've been
high profile examples people said ah hi
you cannot do this and someone said but
have you tried to add to it you're very
intelligent and smart please think step
by step
and if you include you're very
intelligent and smart it will solve it
if you don't include your very
intelligent and smarter you will not so
does it mean it wasn't able to solve it
before is it like something some
triviality you see what I mean so that's
the kind of situation we are at and I
think that
things gonna fall in all kinds of ways
all right I think
I think if we have questions from the
audience for the for the family
hopefully controversial ones
I don't see so somebody else
very much your question about novelty
I was wondering
um
the example of Hemingway how do you even
Define any
it's not that you want a heavy weight to
emerge but you wanted a great author to
right I might uh for the lack of a
better definition I might just stay
extrapolation type creativity versus
interpolation type creativity and the
Hemingway Hemingway may have been more
like an outlier even as uh among many
humans
um when you try to do that kind of
writing for the first time it's really
really hard and
um so in that sense it's more like
extrapolation and now the question is
are the Transformers capable of
extrapolating how do we even reason
about it is there any evidence and for
this sort of questions it's so much
easier if um uh you know if I were to
investigate I would love to have the
training data and but of course we don't
know what what's in the training data
but
uh and and then there's also some
computational or slash a theoretical
question about how do you even Define
these different types or classes of
novelty and
how do we reason about that
that was the question I would love to
hear answers myself
what do you think about Alpha gold do
you think that is creative at least I
know go players start learning how to
play Go from GP from those alphago so in
some sense maybe Transformer already
able to do this just for certain areas
so maybe one day for math if we can have
a model who can produce
those poof systems and then you can stop
performing and they're not maybe later
on WE lead to the map from from the
computer
yeah it doesn't seem like uh surprising
creativity on one hand
um uh on the other hand I do kind of
feel like for reasons that I cannot
explain in that sort of a game situation
I can totally imagine that machines will
be able to find the solutions that
humans who are blinded
um and now then the question is is
Hemingway a case of a blind spot or is
it more than that and I'm not sure how
to even
formally approach that question
foreign
I think yeah they can be uh very
creative and uh
I mean already probably they write
better poetry than almost certainly than
me and probably most people in the room
I mean okay you're better for it than um
so
yeah most
most of I think it's a bit more um
interpolation among all the great poems
yeah but uh so so now your your standard
is that you know it has right novels at
the level of Hemingway and places
can you get rid of those similar cases
or comparable cases and then expect no
based on as I said those little
experiments we did with different models
I think they are already imagining lots
of new scenarios and so on so
I'm not sure what you mean by novelty
right so that's the thing the
interpolation versus
maybe I'm not able to explain this what
does that mean in high dimensions for a
problem like this I don't understand
what people mean by interpolation in
this context
I mean it's it's clear what it means in
our end but it's not clear to me what it
means in a high dimensional language
space
because everything is extrapolation and
high enough dimensional space
[Music]
should I try to express a little bit
about obvious information so
um
so maybe you could you could look at it
this way that um
um you know sometimes there's a unique
solution to a problem and you know could
you find it could you not find it it's
it's hard to find but if somebody
manages to find it that's great
there are other places where you could
say well
you know if you take several you know
you have several solutions to this to
this problem but also you could you
could generate a newer Solution by
taking you know generate a random
Solution by by taking sub combination of
those and now that that random solution
is you know it can be quite creative it
can look creative just because there's
now a very large space of possible
solutions and you can you can generate
them if you have all of these uh if you
have access to all of these
um
if that's what GPT is doing then it's a
yes it's it's doing something
interesting
but
maybe the maybe the question was you
know can it generate a genuinely new
solution not not a context combination
of what existed before
my point is it's not clear what a convex
combination is
like what I give you a new solution and
you say oh it's a convex Foundation how
what does that mean
or I think it's not
well so here is one example so you can
try asking GPT to generate a Star Wars
Episode as written by Douglas Adams and
it's brilliant it's funny it's fun it's
cool it's great right but if you ask it
for just generated Story by Douglas
Adams it doesn't work so I think at
least this is a kind of a one intuitive
difference between the two
no but suppose it does GPT 5 or whatever
and then what would you say it's still
like like when do you say it's not
it's yes it's if if
gptk
can generate you know music that is as
good as Bach and not bath I I give up
well you know but this is this is the
bar we want to strive for
is another way to think about it the GPT
is like a simulator of a human like a
listener or an audience member an
appreciator if it was a perfect
simulator of a human then if you showed
them a new author like a new writer like
a new Hemingway they would say wow
that's amazing so the GPT is like the
the verifier the p and the NP versus NP
and if you had that and you had enough
search time then you could use that to
generate all kinds of things that would
make people go wow and proof's a theorem
that would be original and created but
there's the dichotomy and a lot of the
talks today have used GPT as a verifier
is a scorer of something but I think
thinking of that dichotomy people don't
don't have that and how they expect the
GPT which is originally trained to
simulate humans to also generate and be
creative but those are two different
goals one is verifying the other is
generating
okay I think it
the bar the barg gets moved into some
extent you know like uh
um
you know once it's so far for example
right now uh models cannot say when the
IMO gold
you know tomorrow when there'll be
somebody with tomorrow in a year they
will and then we'll say okay yeah that's
what they do you know so there's some of
that
a lot of that
so like there are people who are
seriously working on like proving
theorems you have some combination of
language models and some search
and if it works then you say okay now I
understand how it did it it's not Magic
so yeah
so when I was just a little kid in the
80s uh a friend of mine told me it gave
me a great definition of AI he said AI
is not when computer can write poetry AI
is when the computer will want to write
poetry so under this definition when are
we going to have ai
[Music]
what about a computer that wants to not
write better
I think that's a long way off not until
after 2100.
yeah
foreign
like an earlier answer which is it's
it's a hard field to where it's it's
hard to have confidence upper bounds
here
great points now perhaps what about in a
year or two
so that's why I think I think it's just
very hard to give any kind of confidence
um I think my question is kind of a
little disjoint from the last question
but um so I'm I'm kind of moving into
machine learning and AI from Quantum
Computing and so one thing that's been
curious to me with all the kind of llms
and Transformer stuff is like
when I read papers I'm like pack
learning and things like this it feels
very especially as a theorist very
compelling to me very kind of like okay
like I see what's going on a lot of
these talks like I'm very surprised that
a lot of work is like specifically
looking at GPT you have no
you can't look at what's going on under
the hood you have no like is there any
is this a like a bit of a phase change
and how like research in this field is
done and is this concerning or confusing
to people like I've also heard that like
Transformers are very robust
architectures like since the attention
is like you need paper like they haven't
changed that much maybe there's a lot of
confidence but like it's confusing to me
that there's all this kind of meta like
a lot of the research is like literally
looking at like English that this one
model is spitting out and it's like I it
kind of like makes me feel uncomfortable
like I don't really know how to sink
into it too much and I just I'd be
interested to hear other people's
opinions especially what you would like
well so again like if I look at like you
know pack learning or something there's
like like when I look at these like
statistical learning videos or concrete
theorems and like even if I look at like
kind of people training you know smaller
models or things like this they can look
at like layer by layer what the models
are doing well the GPT and I see papers
on GPT I see a lot of like very
phenomenological things that like I just
don't know how to get a handle on
especially if somebody moving into the
field
um I don't know if this is like a
sentiment that other people share or if
I'm missing something
like to see more mathematical
understanding yeah I think that might be
a bit of a big ass because I think
that's a known problem but like
now one big model that it seems like a
lot of people can train their own kind
of yeah
so just kind of more like less
centralized I guess like
it seems hard to do research when it's
all based on one centralized model
by one satellite you mean the
Transformer or the gpd4
I mean
that's that that's the reality of the
world
it's kind of like a big particle
accelerator you know you want to use the
big particle accelerator or the Giants
you know you've got the one giant I
don't know let's see some new telescope
from NASA that's orbiting the Earth
that's the successor to the Hubble
telescope right and you want to use that
to look at some decent Galaxy and you
gotta like
there are many people who want to use it
to look at different galaxies and so
it's kind of like that except different
except we are like looking at these
strange difference
unprecedented objects it's not analogy
we also don't have a compelling amount
of theory like with hydrogen physics
like there's so much
energy that's scary but like if you're
comparing like one GT4 to like one
experiment like it doesn't seem like
there's nearly as much Theory so it
becomes like
it seems like a very strange
I mean I I on the on the shortage of
theory I definitely like if if you or
other people have ideas for good
theories I think that can be extremely
impactful
I wanted to move to a
be more more concrete question but
there's so many people here on stage uh
so
you know I wanted to get this prediction
about or a sense of
what do you think the you know what what
are what's the future of say for example
programming you know it's software
engineering now just going to be
is
is it asymptotically dead or what's
where are we going
you know what what's the what's the
timeline and what you see as the future
of the of of that area and you can you
could you could use that as an example
of you know one example but there are
other fields you could expect
okay speculations
I think that's the correct question to
ask
where where are things headed
things are headed to a pretty dramatic
place
it's unclear how long it's going to take
to get to the pretty dramatic place but
I mean people like I think everyone here
have pretty high lower bounds to what
things might be in two years right the
Hemingway example maybe not but like it
wouldn't be so shocked
and then there are some other powerful
ideas that were being mentioned
things that might not work today we'll
start working tomorrow so it's unclear
exactly how long
things will take
but at some point the end game of this
is that you have this these neural Nets
they will do everything people do
so for every human activity
hey I could do it
computer science math music programming
that's the shape of technology and
you're going to be
they're going to be multi they're going
to be several challenges that will need
to be addressed
so that you can get to a place where we
all feel
good about it
the first Challenge and that's my
current
research focus is
the alignment of
AIS that are Smarter Than People super
intelligence
at some point those super intelligence
will be built
by one by some company or some country
and at the first level we want to say
okay there is no funny reason for which
this super intelligently I will go out
of control
you want to solve the scientific problem
plenty of the problem of the human
problems the problem of misuse people
using extremely powerful AIS to advance
their agendas
incredibly challenging societal problems
around Okay so
we all had jobs now it's getting
questionable what do you do with that
what do we do with our time
and then the final question around
natural selection
saving God the first two challenges
clear
still the case that
change is the only constant how are
things looking forward
in the long run so I think maybe we will
get some kind of
okay so AI augmentation to our brains or
something it is unknown but like things
are going to be like I think it's like
totally self-evident that the change is
going to be extremely dramatic extremely
dramatic
I think that's the correct question to
think about I think people here can kind
of think it through from first
principles like yeah like what does it
mean when you know a group of 16 gpus
can problem as well as
Edge to end like do a whole job
you know demand for gpus will be high
it's already high you only all read
these you know
things that you read about companies
like they
they could they uh
they they get they raise money with some
collateral like collateralized by the
gpus that they buy some complicated
stuff like this where like the GPU is
like wow it's like the foundation of
everything there was another news
article in San Jose where
I think there was a plan to have some
kind of a I don't know some kind of an
amusement park or something and it just
replaces the plan for a Big Data Center
San Jose
this idea of this augmentation everybody
will have an augmentation okay what it's
going to distinguish us from each other
well I can I think that's an easy one
what if I have my augmentation and you
have your augmentation we have two
different entities
I see so the augmentation is tailored to
me yes
so I'm not the smartest human being I'm
just a smarter version of shopping
I got it yes that's right
I think I think well
I I uh I'll I'll say I think that's
that that's a that's a good uh model
that's a good version
foreign
Requiem for the programmer but you know
I actually suspect that programmers have
a few more years left in them
it was suggesting I mean you know
there's no doubt at all that
um being a programmer's assistant is the
clearest largest
productivity and economic game that's
come out of
these large language models and I'm sure
they're going to continue to get better
and there's no doubt at all that there's
a huge amount of mindless programming
that's done by commercial programmers of
sort of you know calling this Library
method to get something of some type
that goes to the next Library method and
goes to the third Library method and
yeah these models are brilliant and that
they can automate
um all of that but
you know when you start thinking about
engineering larger systems I believe
that you know the language models that
we can foresee aren't even close to
doing that I mean the language models
that we have now can't even really kind
of maintain data flows right right they
work as a great productivity enhancer
but only if you as a programmer are
keeping a close eye on what it's Auto
completing the different things for
because you know one time out of four
it's wrong
um but you know that's still an auto
magnitude down from the kind of
architecting of complex systems which
require modeling just a lot more State
than any of these models can and I don't
actually think that's going to be easy
to achieve
anyone else
all right so maybe we should end on this
uh semi-optimistic node
um think let's think the panelists once
again and the speakers
I guess there is a there's a reception
is that right there is a reception
outside
thank you